So that's the basic narrative I was here and I'm trying to go there and so if
you're asking your kindergarten kid what they did today at school and teaching
them to tell a story,
they might say,
well I was at home and then mom took me to kindergarten.
It's like not a very exciting story but it's a story and then a little more
exciting story might be
I was at home,
my mom took me to school and on the way there are big dog ran up to the fence
and barked at me and the right question that would follow that story is,
okay,
what did you do?
And that's a real story because the kid says,
well look,
I was in this frame of reference and I was aiming at goal a B actually I was
aiming at point B and while I was aiming at point B an acting out the processes
that would lead me there,
something unexpected happened.
That's a story.
And then you say,
well what did you do?
And the kid might say,
well,
you know,
I was really scared and I hid behind mum or so that would be one response and we
still went to kindergarten and I was okay,
it's pretty good,
pretty good.
Or The kid might say,
well I wasn't scared at all because I know that if you stand up to dogs,
they usually leave you alone.
And we went to kindergarten and that was okay.
And you know,
the kid is trained to tell really they're trying to tell a little hero story and
if they're successful in the accounter with the thing that's unknown,
then they triumph as a consequence of their encounter with the unexpected.
And poof,
you know that's successful at a pace.
You Pat them on the head and you say,
yeah,
that's really good.
They kind of smile and you know you're teaching them,
you're teaching them how to comprehend their existence in a narrative structure
and you're also teaching them what that narrative structure should be.
So this is like a Meta narrative and the Meta narrative says you were going from
point a to point B.
That's the oval on that left.
And then something completely bizarre happened.
Like I was betrayed and then I was in this terrible place for quite a long
period of time,
a chaotic place.
But I learned a bunch and I put myself back together and I'm a wiser person as a
consequence of the encounter,
right?
Everyone knows that story.
And that's paradise.
Paradise lost,
paradise regained.
It's a cultural meta-narrative and,
and it's a story that every,
like it's a human story.
It's an apocalyptic story.
That's why everybody's always all apocalyptic about everything,
right?
Apocalypse of the week,
we're going to run out of oil,
we're going to run out of gas.
There's too much carbon dioxide.
The Chinese are going to take over the world.
We're ruining the Co.
We're ruining the ecology,
the oceans running out of fish.
You know,
the world is getting too hot.
It was getting too cold in 1970 when I was about your age.
It's like apocalypse of the week.
Why?
Because things fall apart and because they can fall apart completely and they
often do.
And so everyone's always on the alert for like the next potential apocalypse.
And it's no wonder,
you know,
a permanent characteristic of life that things can radically fall apart.
Now,
luckily it's a permanent characteristic of life that they can actually also
radically come back together.
And it turns out that whether or not they radically come together,
depends to some degree on how you choose to act when they fall apart.